[Music]  you look like an angel  I'm [ __ ] aimed at your mouth I don't  believe you let me prove it the ground  we walk one we could fall through at any  time or no one would care but why should  I always be like that because it is  whether you think you can never win  how important things are possible but  kindness and love and changer  whatever we're gonna do now your lower  darling won't for nothing in our loving  care  child should be able to play now and  then especially Christmas oh and some  people should learn to mind our business  don't know what the world is like but I  wanted to see for myself  Paris is a tinderbox you'll only take a  spark to set it off  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  and epic six-part drama lay miserab on  bbc1  you